pop un jour un homme est parti sur la
mer il devait ressembler à celui ci qui
va sur son radeau vers une maigre pêche
près des côtes de tunisie
un jour un homme est parti sur l'année
et la grande aventure a commencé
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
quelques milliers d'années plus tard
d'autres hommes ont regardé notre
planète depuis la lune
pour ces hommes de l'espace la terre
c'est d'abord la mer
notre monde le voici un vaste océan
[Applaudissements]
70 % de la superficie totale du globe
alors pas étonnant que l'histoire des
hommes depuis nos et son arche soit la
langue découverte de cette mère qui nous
entoure
comment la raconter cette histoire la
mer les hommes les bateaux en voici un
en plein pacifique avec à son bord un
homme de la voix jean campistro
il n'a qu'une passion
là mais pour moi c'est un monde à part
ce sont deux dimensions
c'est une palette de couleurs sons des
odeurs
c'est une piste d'hommes livre c'est un
lieu d'évasion
et en même temps c'est une arène où on
se mesure avec les éléments c'est à dire
avec la vérité
c'est ce qu'ont dû ressentir les
premiers marins les hommes qui sont
partis les premiers sont amers pense pas
pense pas je pense que les premiers
hommes sont partis ce qui avait
nécessité de partir
ouah qu'ils ont utilisé la mer par
nécessité les premiers hommes devaient
avoir besoin de franchir à détroit
devait avoir besoin de manger devait
avoir des ambitions guerrière cologna ge
je crois que ça se limite à ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à vingt mille kilomètres de là au bord
de la méditerranée
un autre homme arrivé à cette enfance de
la marion alain bond a bien sûr le
l'histoire de la marine commence par
l'histoire des rapports entre l'homme et
la mer et la marine n'est venu que de ce
que kipling appelait l'insatiable
curiosité
en fait il ya eu d'abord l'homme qui
vivait sur la terre et puis brusquement
rencontre éléments liquides alors
immédiatement une espèce de symbiose une
espèce de vie en commun une espèce de de
collaboration alors que dans toutes les
civilisations primitives qui était basé
sur l'économie de cueillette ça
comprenez sans rien rendre une seule
population n'a jamais connu la famine
à l'intérieur il ya eu des moments où
parce qu'il avait fait froid parce qu'il
avait trop plu parce qu'ils avaient pas
eu de soleil on a manqué de gibier et
surtout on a manqué de vire végétaux
frais sur le bord de la mer jamais et
les populations primitives qui vivait en
nomade au bord de la mer comme sur
l'intérieur des terres s'y sont pas
trompés et n'ont jamais quitté le bord
de mer c'est à dire que la mer dès le
départ a été la fait qu au fond l'appel
la mère en france s est presque
symbolique
on pourrait l'appeler la mère aimait
heureux car ça a été la mater la terreur
à la latine de tout et nuit d'où tout
est né et puis bien sûr la pêche côtière
s'est jusque là ou là où ce que l'homme
peut aller avant de perdre pied et
immédiatement vient la curiosité
insatiable de l'homme qui va plus loin
et c'est le premier bateau c'est le
tronc d'arbre c'est le tronc d'arbre
creuser pour ne pas être mouillé dedans
et c'est le début de l'histoire de la
marine quand vous pensez à l'histoire de
la marine
qu'est ce qui vous vient à l'esprit
quelles sont les bateaux et les hommes
viabilité a personnellement les bateaux
polynésiens les drakkars les bateaux
arabe bathory gip siens
et enfin ces bateaux français de aubord
xviie ou xviiie siècle puis ensuite
toute la génération des clippers
pourquoi ces bateaux pour qu est ce qui
vous intéresse plus que les autres parce
que chacun des bateaux dont tu parles et
marquent une époque dans l'histoire de
l'humanité et en particulier dans
l'histoire de l'architecturé navale
on ne peut pas considérer qu'il ya une
chronologie absolue en matière
d'architecturé navale temps donné par
exemple que les bateaux polynésien avait
plusieurs siècles d' avance sur tous les
autres bateaux elle est et si parfaite
ces pirogues polynésiennes qu'elles ont
traversé les siècles
les voici aujourd'hui à tahiti gear
différentes
servi par les mêmes joyeuse équipe de
robustes pagayeurs les enfourchent leur
masse embarcations qu'ils ont creusée
assemblée avec le même amour là même
lente obstination qui ignorent notre
temps notre précipitation un témoignage
précieux sur la naissance de la
navigation le tronc d'arbre c'est un
jour transformer en coop longue et fine
qu un balancier équilibre parfaitement
l'homme s'est senti tout d'un coup les
jeunes et libres
alors il a voulu partir plus loin
il est sale est quelque chose de plus
lourd de plus solide
ces deux pirogues de haute mer pour les
expéditions au delà de l'horizon
à peu près convenablement reconstituer
ce sont les protecteurs
c'est une sorte de monument national
pour tous les haïtiens comme tout à
salma qui la fait revivre et qui veille
sur elle
jalousement ses pilotes d'anciens tant
que nous on sait très utilisés pour
leurs voyages dans les îles et on
pourrait mettre facilement 80 go lamblin
défi c'est à dire une trentaine de la
mer et ses crocs de passagers est porté
avec des petits cochons par exemple
d'aider où il partait avec tout cela via
free parties à plusieurs mais ils
n'arrivent pas tous quelques uns les
autres
mais quel voyage
les maoris pense-t-on étaient parties de
l'inde au 3e siècle avant jésus-christ
vers les îles tonga et samoa
deux siècles plus tard on les retrouve
aux îles de la société à tahiti où il
rayonne vers hawaii à 2300 milles marins
c'est à dire 4200 km vers la nouvelle
zélande où il arrive au xvème siècle
après un voyage de 3800 km ils
atteindront même l'île de pâques à 4100
km
[Musique]
notre ami campistron continuent à
évoquer le passé de la marine très loin
dans le temps
très loin du pacifique j'ai dessiné
des bateaux à travers l'histoire ici
vous avez le plus ancien bateau
retrouver un bateau égyptien de la
flotte du foot
il est remarquable de penser qu' il ya
3000 ans l'homme était capable de
réaliser de dessiner des coques et des
ensembles aussi merveilleux aussi
esthétique c'est un bateau qui fait une
vingtaine de mètres de long et qui
pouvait contenir le plus d'une centaine
de passagers
le plan de voilure signifie que ce
bateau naviguer dans des régions où il y
avait peu de vent
la flotte du pount c'était les bateaux
envoyés par le pharaon vers le pays
légendaire de pount le soudan ou même
l'inde pense-t-on
les temples disent qu'il rapportait
alors ni voir les épices
mais les égyptiens n'étaient pas
vraiment des bas rhin il n'allait pas
bien loin
guère au delà de ces paresseuse remontée
du nil
au delà du nil il y avait cette petite
mer qui leur semblait si grande
perdu dans le passé de loin d'un peuple
de marins phéniciens très toi aller au
devant de l'inconnu on a eu beau avancer
avancer on voyait rien de l'autre côté
il y avait en plus les courants avait
les vents et d'où cette grande légende
la mer est bonne ici elle est généreuse
ici mais d'une part elle rend demain
renferme des monstres qui a ressenti
quelques fois des animaux énorme
je pense que la tête des hommes
rencontrant le premier rôle qu'un de s'y
mettre
ça doit être vraiment la révélation
d'une espèce de d'enfer qui se trouvait
quelque part car il n'était pas
habituellement sur la cause et on le
rencontrait donc tu n'es tu que tu pars
tu alors cette notion de la terre plate
et donc c'est tout qui devait tomber
quelque part et la grande cataractes du
bout de la mer
puis vinrent les grecs
dans la légende ou peut-être dans
l'histoire ulysse se promène on ne se
trouve au milieu des sirènes et des
tempêtes un très grand navigateur à greg
de marseille pythéas osent affronter
l'atlantique
il sera le premier marin à avoir la
banquise et combien de bataille fameuse
comme ça la mine où la flotte perse est
détruite mais surtout qu'elle sort du
commerce sur la mer
ici à delos au coeur de l'archipel des
cyclades les ruines du port témoigne
sous le soleil grec de la puissance
maritime et commercial d'athènes
ici dans ses entrepôts ses magasins à
ses quais des centaines d'esclaves
débarquer chaque jour pour être vendus
au milieu d'un affirmant incroyable
dans une ruelle du port nous avons
retrouvé un témoignage bien émouvant
pour l'histoire un jeune archéologue
français philippe fraisse nous avait dit
pour voir ce qui était la marine grecque
c'est ici qu'il faut filmer et nous
voilà dans une maison pas très loin du
port une maison comme vous le voyez avec
encore des stucs très bien conservé et
sur ses stucs des graffitis que l'on
peut dater de la fin du iième siècle
début du premier siècle
l'heure était donc très facile avec des
pointes de couteaux ou des petits outils
de dessiner à la fois des animaux un peu
fantastique de graver leur nom mais
surtout de dessiner ses bateaux que vous
voyez très distinctement avec une voile
très très grande
un mât très haut une coque qui semble
posséder de chaque côté une rangée de
ram ou celui là encore avec sa voile à
nouveau une coque très élancée qui se
perd au milieu des signatures ou
d'autres graffitis moins lisible qui
étaient ces marins qui gravait dans le
plâtre les maladroites et précieuses
images de leur bateau un homme les a
rencontrés au fond de l'eau en allant à
la recherche des épaves de méditerranée
si jacques yves cousteau cadres et ont
trouvé le crâne d'un des marins qui
étaient encore conservées sous la vase
ça ce sont des moments d'émotion
attentes
mais le moins d'objets usuels par
exemple un beigne un jeu des osselets
avec lequel ils jouaient eux
ça fait immédiatement revivre la vie à
bord on imagine imagine les gens sur le
rap la jav en train de jouer en votant
j'ai aussi la façon très astucieuse
ont-ils organiser le chargement des
amphores enfin imbriquées les unes dans
les autres sont à bord absolument aucune
possibilité de jouer au roulis tout ça
est très remarquable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
par ces campagnes de plonger comme celle
de mahdia en tunisie où devant l'île
grecque d'anticythère le commandant
cousteau a contribué à renouveler l'idée
que l'on se faisait de la marine ancien
d'abord qu'ils étaient beaucoup plus
évoluée que nous ne croyons le navire
était très perfectionné par exemple les
clous de cuivre qui fixe et le doublage
de plomb sur la coque était
soigneusement gironné de plomb la tête
de ces clous étaient environnés de plomb
de façon à garantir garantir contre les
effets de galvanoplastie leaf électrique
entre le cuivre le plomb je crois qu'il
n'explique est pas le phénomène mais il
le connaissait donc voilà un exemple par
exemple qui nous montrer que c'est des
anciens étaient beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus avancé logo plus perfectionné que
nous ne pensions ensuite par exemple le
fait que les phéniciens utiliser le
contre courant profond du détroit de
gibraltar pour sortir de la méditerranée
contre le vent en immergeant à 200
mètres il encore flottante
eh bien c'était c'était quand même pour
nous et nos révélations et
il ya comme ça toute une série devant la
taille aussi des bateaux à nadia le
bateau ses 40 mètres de long et faisait
trois fois le tonnage à calypso et
le navire d'anticythère également en
séquences ce que j'en ai déduit de ses
explorations son admiration pour les
navigateurs antique aussi le plus
remarquable bateaux de guerre de
l'antiquité grecque
il s'agit d'une galère authentique elle
comprenait 200 rameurs un chiffre
absolument considérable on commence à
voir apparaître les formes de voile
extrêmement moderne et propulsive et ses
bateaux dans les carènes sont
merveilleuses comme on peut bien le voir
était capable de remonter quand même au
vent
ici vous avez l'accord bitat latine le
bateau de commerce et de transport de
rome de la flotte de commerce de rome
qui a une influence considérable en
méditerranée pendant plusieurs siècles
on commence à voir apparaître ici
cette petite voile à l'avant qui va
avoir un effet directionnelle on voit
aussi la possibilité de réduire la toile
par panneaux entier au dessus des perles
tous ces navires de roms arrivés ici à
austin le grand port de la métropole
impérial aujourd'hui complètement à
l'intérieur des terres lire windows ti
évoque pourtant bien ce qu'était la
marine de commerce romaine écoutons
attilio kokari historien italien
il faut évidemment faire un petit effort
d'imagination et penser à cette zone
couverte par des arcades rempli de
colonnes et dans ses colonnades dans
cette espèce de couloir où il y avait
des magasins apple ont l'un comme saint
lô des agences de navigation à voile a
une qui peut très bien s approcher comme
souvenir à la france voilà une na'vi
narbonnais mme sess c'est-à-dire jeune
agence de commerce qui avait ses
échanges avec la gaule
voilà les mosaïques qui est pas
seulement un document mais aussi un
exemple d'art un mosaïque l'époque
impériale où est représenté un bateau de
commerce romain caractérisé par sa poupe
à col de cygne et c'est la tête d'un
signe qui est toujours présentes sur le
bateau de commerce le bateau marchand
romain le double team ont par exemple le
double gouvernail
organisé et formé par deux grands ram un
des deux côtés du bateau la grande voile
le m'a soutenu par 4 ou bien simplement
une un gréement très simple et très
essentiel et à côté c'est un marchand
d'animaux pour réussir qu'un importateur
d'animaux d'afrique pour les jeux de
cirque et voilà encore à côté
encore un souvenir de france très
probablement cette mosaïque représente
la bouche du rhône avec sa sortie à la
mer dans la mer n'est ce pas et au
sommet du dessin de la mosaïque
voilà le pont du rhône le pont en bois
du rhône qui traversait d'un côté à
l'autre de la flèche si on le voit un
peu attentivement sur les regarde un peu
attentivement on se rend bien compte que
la musique est un perspective on voit
très bien la partie l'appelant celle du
de plancher en bois et les deux côtés
qui protégeait le passage du pont oui
les bateaux romain remonter les fleuves
remonté le rhône trade à l'intérieur
comme on peut boire très bien peut-être
mieux encore dans la moselle qui suit
qui est peut-être une de plus
intéressante de cette zone dans laquelle
nous sommes maintenant c'est toujours le
pavé d'une agence de commerce
ces deux bateaux romain celui de droite
et le plus grand comme importance compte
en âge de bateaux de l'autre est en
train de décharger la marchandise sur le
bateau plus petit sur la gauche qui va
transporter ces qui a reçu jusqu'à rome
a observé encore que l'homme qui
décharge a sur ses épaules sur son dos
in an fort et on peut considérer sans
ironie le conteneur de l'époque on n'a
jamais retrouvé d'autres récipients que
des amphores dans lequel place et
l'huile le grain la farine le blé tout
tous été transportés par moyen d un fort
et notre plongeur retrouve curieusement
les gestes fixé voici deux mille ans par
la mosaïque au début de l'ère chrétienne
les enfants seront remplacés par les
tonneaux de bois invention gauloise et
du coup on ne retrouvera plus rien dans
les états
marine ostrom nôtre mais orgueilleuse et
implacable l'affirmation de la puissance
de rome
mais combien avec il fallut de bataille
navale pour que règne la pax romana la
paix romaine votre carthage contre les
rebelles de marc-antoine à axione contre
les pirates qui pendant longtemps a
festhéa les grandes lignes commerciales
c'est avec ces navires que rome écrasa
tous ses adversaires débit rennes les
trirème énorme galère actionné par les
centaine de rameurs mais comment
l'histoire nous dit que les romains
n'était pas de très bons marins leur
secret ils avaient inventé la fente reid
marie pas de manoeuvres savante
le res aux abords des l'ennemi et les
redoutables légionnaires avancés les
pays hôtes et raser tout
ainsi rouleront les flottes de rome
lempire de byzance qui lui succédera ne
construira pas des bateaux très
différents
pour arriver à un type de navire
vraiment nouveau il faut sauter quelques
siècles aller vers le nord vers la
scandinavie le pays des vikings
c'est un bateau extraordinaire c'est le
bateau d'oseberg le bateau d'oseberg des
vikings qui est vraiment le symbole de
cette voile du nord dont on a tant parlé
de ses marins exceptionnels qui ont
peut-être découvert l'amérique bien
avant christophe colomb sur le plan
esthétique
je crois que ce sont parmi les plus
beaux bateaux qui ont jamais été
dessinés au monde le voici le teneur le
bateau victime
la copie d'un vaisseau trouvait dans une
tombe danemark
long de 17 mètres large de plus de 2 m
il file aujourd'hui pour nous dans un
fjord danois
24 hommes du nord ont revêtu le costume
de leurs ancêtres et revivent pour nous
ce grand moment de leur histoire avec
que l'un des meilleurs spécialistes des
vikings
régis boyer cette reproduction exacte au
détail près d'un bateau de guerre
capable de voler ou 9ème 10ème siècle
ils sont exactement dans le costume de
l'époque de costumes qui est véridique
dans les moindres détails et nous sommes
partis pour une aventure voici le chef
il est à l'avant de son bateau il tient
son épée qui est authentique et puis
voici ces sommes par exemple vous voyez
cet homme en bray ce sont des vêtements
se dit que les scandinaves en tas de
jetons
celui ci est peut-être plus intéressant
une très belle tunique the parade
il a aussi des reproductions de bijoux
vikings authentique et en particulier le
fameux marteau de thor
il porte à la ceinture la redoutable
d'agde avec wacken en donner le coup de
grâce des guerriers des commerçants qui
était-il celi qui le mot lui-même veut
dire homme des baies les hommes qui
descendirent des fientes norvège de
suède ou du danemark aux alentours du
viiie siècle
sans doute avait dit le même visage le
même regard bleu et froid la même
obstination lente et grave
[Musique]
les prédateurs ils n'avaient rien la
barre des moineaux plus lent de riches
fermiers avaient tous
alors ils se sont glissés le long des
côtes de l'europe de la russie à
l'espagne une rumeur de terreur s'est
répandue comme la peste
il arrive
les longs bateau silencieux remonte les
fleuves il arrive un verdict nord chacun
affûte sa dague encore quelques instants
et ce sera la curée jusqu'ici personne
ne sait qu'ils sont là quand on les
verra il sera trop tard
il n'y avait pas à l'époque de moyens de
parade contre lui il va très vite ils
virent pratiquement sur place
il a un tirant d'eau si faible qu'il
peut circuler comme vous le voyez ici
même dans un fond d'eau ridicule
il marche à la rame il marche à la voile
il marche à la godille on le transporte
entre équipages se fit à le transporter
pour passer d'un chenal à un autre
éventuellement on peut le rouler sur des
rondins pour le déplacer il est
pratiquement insaisissable les vikings
s'embusquer dans une petite île de
l'intérieur à l'embouchure d'une rivière
la loire la seine la tamise il
surgissait au moment venu lorsque les
populations locales était le moins
prévenu contre eux c'est à dire un jour
de fête un dimanche ou un jour de très
mauvais temps
/ jce est à toute vitesse il débarquait
de ce bateau de guerre qu'il faisait
leur coup de main il mettait le feu
partout et vite ils seront embarqués
avant que les populations attendent sur
16e et disparus l'armé absolue la
terreur personnifié de l'ancêtre du
blitzkrieg
m
à
est ce que votre pain au fond leur
férocité les pépins après tous à
l'unisson de la férocité du temps nord
d'ailleurs il faut un peut détruire une
autre légende aussi ils n'étaient pas
plus féroce et probablement moins
d'ailleurs que leurs contemporains les
hongrois où les musulmans qui sur
d'autres points du globe comme été les
mêmes déprédations mais peut-être avec
un peu moins de succès que seulement il
ne faut pas oublier que presque tous les
témoins dont nous disposons pour les
connaître
ce sont les clercs les moines apeuré de
tous nos couvents et abbayes détester
incendié par les vikings qui ont donc
écrit des pages atroce avec des
exagérations grandiloquence ce sont des
gens qui vivaient dans des pays pauvres
qui avait à se défendre contre un climat
sol extrêmement ingrat qui aurait pu
végéter vivoter et qui se sont battus
contre les éléments qui ont eu le
courage de sortir de leur milieu de
partir à l'aventuré d'aller chercher
ailleurs ce qu'ils ne trouvaient pas
chez eux
[Musique]
c'est bien c'est une voile rectangulaire
qui est faite de long les parallèles ne
pouvait s'imposer et keith manoeuvre
extrêmement simplement par un système de
haubans à gauche et à droite et de
poulies en boîte qu'ils viennent de
descendre ses voiles étaient en brad
rossier tissés à la maison avec le poil
des moutons mérinos si célèbre l'époque
et quand on l'est encore aujourd'hui en
islande la vitesse
la ram c'est l attaque c'était la guerre
l'avoine c'est le voyage c'est la
découverte
les vikings ont d'abord rejoint les
kospi d'irlande
à la fin du neuvième siècle ils partent
vers la tente
ou est ce qu'il fallait pour s'orienter
pour m'habituer d'entretien de
l'aviation alors c'est là certainement
le problème le plus passionnant et le
plus irritant que pose la navigation des
vikings d'autant qu' il était capable de
se diriger pendant de très longues
périodes de temps et sur des itinéraires
très donc avec une précision qui confond
la migration aujourd'hui je dispose est
certainement de divers instruments dont
nous ne savons rien il n'avait
évidemment pas debout seul le plus
vraisemblable
certainement qu'il se repérer d'après la
tradition orale sur des détails tout à
fait matériel et banale qui était
transmis et que connaisse encore les
pêcheurs aujourd'hui vous aurez si vous
voulez la dernière théorie à la mode ces
derniers temps consiste à parler de la
pierre soler sous l'arche tail dont
voici un exemplaire qui est un cristal
qui est un quartz à double diffraction
ce cristal la vertu de permettre de
déceler l'emplacement exact du soleil il
même par temps très ouvert très nuageux
alors on le met devant l'oeil ainsi et
on le promène dans le ciel et au moment
où ils passent devant le soleil ils
s'éclairent il
une sorte de ligne lumineuse se dessine
à ce moment là on connaît l'emplacement
précis du soleil et donc on est censé
savoir retrouver sa direction par
rapport à l'emplacement du salaire
en 874 les vikings traverse tout le nord
de l'atlantique et atteignent d'islande
à 1000 kilomètres de la norvège
les raisons de notre admiration c'est
qu'ils sont capables de tenir plusieurs
semaines en mer avec des vivres
extrêmement réduite du poisson séché du
beurre salé des algues séchées de la
viande fumée en quantité extrêmement
petit et une réserve d'eau très très
limité il faut conclure qu'il était
capable de supporter des traversées
londe et pénible en se nourrissant taux
minimum sûrs buvant très peu n'y a pas
d'autre explication
ils vont encore plus loin la soif de
l'aventuré chevillée au corps il
atteignait le groënland la grande glace
et au nord de l'atlantique
un épisode tragique de l'histoire des
milliers de colons deakin s'installe au
groenland
le plus célèbre explorateur polaire
français paul-emile-victor midi le
destin de grenade a été découvert en 986
par un homme qui s'appelait erik le
rouge à cause de la couleur de ses
cheveux et qui est revenu ensuite en
islande en appelant lille qui l'avait
découverte groënland la terre verte
non pas du tout parce qu'elle était
verte mais il le dit lui même dans la
saga dit derrick rose erika odeurs parce
qu un aussi joli nom y attirer beaucoup
de colons c'est le premier slogan
publicitaire de l'histoire elle était
peut-être plus verte en effet la terre à
l'époque qu'aujourd'hui et encore ce
n'est pas certaine de 10,2 donc de la
fin du 10ème siècle jusque vers le
xvième siècle on a eu des nouvelles des
vikings grenland est d'abord et pendant
plusieurs siècles parce qu'ils
assuraient eux mêmes les liaisons entre
eux et la métropole
et puis je crois bien que c'est et au
xvème siècle le roi de norvège a vendu
l'exclusivité du commerce avec le green
landes à des marchands de bergues et non
au début ces marchands de bergon
d'assurer les liaisons mais sont rendus
compte que c'était pas du pipi de
corbeau comme disent mes amis et ce qui
vaut et quelques autres que c'était très
difficile et par conséquent petit à
petit ils n'ont plus envoyer de bateaux
et on a oublié les vikings du groenland
sont tous morts ils sont tous morts on a
relevé plus que d'infimes vestiges
autant dire qu ils ont disparu sans
laisser aucune
on est sûr aujourd'hui que les vikings
ont découvert l'amérique en allant jusqu
ici au labrador une terre qu'ils ont
appelée vineland cinq siècles avant
christophe colomb quelle épopée qui
mérite bien cette grande place dans
notre série le groenland l'islande et
même des raids en méditerranée ils se
sont installés en normandie
au détour de l'an mil ils vont vivre
encore une grande aventure une aventure
contée par la fameuse tapisserie de la
reine mathilde la bay'a 1066 les vikings
devenu normand s'embarque pour
l'angleterre 400 cno et l'on vaisseau
une expédition qui réussira ce qu'on ne
reverra pas de sitôt
[Musique]
oh
mais c'est aussi toute une partie de
l'histoire de la marine qui se clôt
alors que les chevaux de guillaume le
conquérant s'élance vers hastings le
monde va changer les bateaux aussi
jean campistron nous montre comment va
évoluer la marine au moyen-âge
c'est très curieux après avoir vu des
bateaux aussi magnifique que les bateaux
égyptiens et méditerranéen il semble que
entre le 10e et le xiième siècle l'homme
retourne un peu en arrière
il cherche à faire des navires
extrêmement important pour l'époque mais
dont les qualités marines ne sont pas
comparables à celles que nous avons vu
précédemment
ici vous avez une carac xiième siècle
est un bateau de transport
celui ci est un bateau germanique qui
appartenait à une chance c'est à dire de
ces compagnies de navigation du nord de
la baltique et la mer du nord
on peut le voir il a trois mâts il a
conservé cette brigantine à l'arrière et
deux phare carré mais cependant on voit
bien que c'est un gros lourde
paris comme pour un tournoi avec les
écus les chevaliers étrangers comme sera
donjon pinçant ces navires que nous
décrit le patron du musée de la marine
le commandant luc mary bale ces bateaux
sont en réalité des thés château
flottant on a déjà bien le château
arrière et le château avant de chacun il
s'agit là de ferrer bateau le plus grand
possible pour l'époque et de se trouver
le plus de 2 de dominer l'adversaire le
mieux possible
donc on a tendance jusqu'à aller au
chavirement on a tendance à charger les
vaisseaux dans les eaux de façon alors à
dominer son ennemi c'est pourquoi ces
bateaux et des dés la hauteur de cette
façon là chateaufort exactement ils sont
encore d une ronde
ils ont tous des voiles carrées comme
l'avait encore là déjà en angleterre
dans le nord
contrairement aux voiles latines du sud
ou autrement ce sont des forteresses
flottante un bateau comme celui ci il va
avoir 50 mètres de long il doit avoir
entre mille a qu'un santenots c'est ce
qu'on faisait à peu près deux plus
grands à l'époque même en méditerranée
est apparu un nouveau type de voile venu
dit on des jonques chinoises et que l'on
a vu aussi se répandre en héros
[Musique]
c'est la voile latine appelé ainsi tout
simplement pour la différencier des
voiles carrées du nord paradoxe elle
sera surtout utilisé par les arabes
[Musique]
c'est un progrès jusqu'ici le vent
poussait la voile comment remonter
contre le vent cette voile triangulaire
très maniable permet de nous voyez de
tromper le vent en le prenant au zig zag
un pas en avant vers une plus grande
liberté de manoeuvre
l'homme n'est plus tributaire de la
direction du vent tous les marins
d'europe
à dr ont bientôt ce nouveau gréement
[Musique]
les arabes pour se lancer à la conquête
de la méditerranée vous combinez les
deux types de voile alors en usage
la voile carrée propulsive et la voile
latine
ainsi naîtra le loudes pour nous voyons
ici le dernier exemplaire à flot le long
des côtes de tunisie
[Applaudissements]
ce fossile marc promène une silhouette
étonnant avec son mât inclinée à 45
degrés disposition pratiquement unique
dans l'histoire de la marine un très bon
bateau qui assurera pendant des siècles
le commerce et le cabotage en
méditerranée cible aussi gracieux qui
survivra jusqu'à notre époque vaincu
seulement par le moteur
ces flottes arabes croisés parfois
violemment
d'autres navires venus du nord de la
méditerranée venue de cette ville de
l'eau dont les palets montrer
l'extraordinaire puissance
reine du commerce les croisades avait
fait sa fortune
c'était venise
1 ville de marco polo en 1271 ils
étaient partis vers la chine à la
recherche de toutes ces merveilles les
épices des soieries la poudre ce qu'il
avait rapporté le rêve de tout un peuple
et ce rêve ici à l'arsenal de venise
animer les milliers de charpentier
d'ingénieurs d'armateurs
[Musique]
on
dans ces immenses chantiers navals oui
il était ainsi à l'époque on pouvait
construire jusqu'à une galère par jour
[Musique]
des centaines de vaisseau qui allait
sillonner la méditerranée
[Musique]
on
chacun dans la fièvre de ce travail de
fourmi savais qu'un jour
derrière ce mur d'enceinte quelque chose
d'autre arriverait on irait plus loin
vers l'inconnu encore fallait-il avoir
les moyens de se diriger sur la mer
l'une de ces républiques maritime qui
dominaient à l'époque la méditerranée
amalfi va donner au monde ce moyen c'est
une histoire peu connue que nous conte
plinio amende dollars historien local
je crois que la plus grande gloire
d'amalfi c'est l'invention de l'avion au
sol par notre concitoyen flavio joy
c'est un personnage légendaire ce n'est
pas parce qu'on n'a pas retrouvé son
acte de naissance nice attend qu'on a
contesté toute cette tradition qui veut
que la boussole et bien été inventé par
fly ou joy un savant l'ingénieur à
gatineau d'arrigo a mis fin à l'inutile
discussions sur l'invention de la
boussole par les chemins noirs ou les
arabes chinois connaissent et l'aiguillé
mentez mais ne s'en servaient pas pour
naviguer constater quand il est allé en
chine surtout à proximité des côtes aux
arabes leurs cartes marines étaient
imprécises ce qui confirme qu'ils ne
possédaient pas la boussole pour
s'orienter
à la fin du moyen âge jusqu'à
l'invention du port tuant les hommes
n'ont guère d'idée précise sur la forme
de leur demande
seule l'europe est à peu près dessiner
la mer du nord à l'espagne et au
portugal avec une vague et bouche du
nord de l'afrique alors apparaît au
portugal un personnage extraordinaire où
à la fin du 14ème siècle dont henry
henry le portugal dit henri navigateur
favori navigateur le mal nommé car lui
même n'a traversé quatre toiles des 30
gibraltar mais il était certain que l'on
pouvait connaître la côte africaine
ces deux côtes africaines dont on avait
entendu parler par la traite des de
l'ivoire etc qui arrivait par la terre
en passant par la mer et il envoie
expédition sur l'expédition pour arriver
à trouver ce qu'avait dit hérodote que
la mer où se trouvait l'egypte était la
même que celle où se trouvait atlantis
c'est-à-dire l'atlantique est en fait la
grande illusion du golfe de guinée qui
pénétrant profondément d'année
l'impression que l'afrique allait se
couper à cet endroit là et c'est à la
recherche de ce passage que les
portugais pendant deux siècles vont
descendre jusqu'à finalement passé le
cap 10 de bonne espérance parce que
c'était enfin l'endroit vous la cote
remonter et au fond hérodote avez raison
les mères étaient jointes é sé an plus
tard se présentait un visionnaire
d'origine espagnole d'origine
probablement juive qui s'appelle
cristobal colo alors là change
totalement notre civilisation
un moment capital
la rencontre pour changer le monde d'un
homme exceptionnel et de conditions
exceptionnelles
la technique a fait un bond la boussole
le gouvernail permettent d'aller loin
sur l'océan
christophe caul il a 46 ans
ce n'est ni un fou ni un rêveur mais
déjà un vieux marin très expérimenté il
connaît tous tes cartes
il a suivi avec passion les récits de
marco polo il a dit au souverain
d'espagne il faut trois ans avant navire
pour aller aux seins des revenus la
terre est ronde
moi j'irai aux indes par l'atlantique en
dix fois moins de temps
toutes les richesses de ces pays
fabuleux seront à vous
début août 1492 trois vaisseaux quitte
le port andalou de palos de moquer d'eux
caravelle une nef l'historien espagnols
martinez hidalgo nous dit d'abord ce
qu'étaient ces bateaux qui allait avoir
tant l'importance dans l'histoire la
caravane à son origine au portugal et en
espagne
c'est une version améliorée de la carac
mauresque un bateau arabe à voiles
latines
ainsi la ligne était encore une
caravelle à voiles latines
quand christophe colomb a fait sa
première escale aux canaries il a fait
changer les voiles et n'avait pas été
efficaces par vent arrière décidé
d'adopter un gréement carré comme sur
l'autre caravelle lapinta avec ce
gréement mieux adapté à la navigation
sur l'atlantique elle devait être
quand christophe colomb est parti pour
son grand voyage c'est à dire la ligne
et la pinta toujours en avant et la nef
plus lentes plus lourdes en arrière la
nef est encore une car aqmi diéval le
grand navire servant au transport des
marchandises
ils avaient besoin d'un équipage
important le gréement est rudimentaire
qu'il fallait du monde pour le
manoeuvrer à bord de la santa maria
on a estimé qu'il n'y ait pas moins de
40 l'équipage se trouvaient généralement
sous une grande tente sur le pont pas
d'autres logements
le seul qui avait ses quartiers étaient
l'amiral christophe colomb les hommes
d'équipage
contrairement à ce qui a été soutenu par
certains historiens amateurs de
sensationnel n'étaient pas des forçats
c'était bel et bien démarré d'excédent
da
après cette escale aux canaries le vrai
départ a lieu dans l' enthousiasme
c'est cela qui est étonnant la pression
des débuts de participer à un événement
historique
collomb est très confiant il croit que
très vite il va trouver ce que les
portugais appel l'île d'antigua aux
antilles
lille en face les cartes la mentionne
avec beaucoup de détails bien que
personne ne l'a encore vu c'est une
légende à l'endroit présumé
il n'y a rien
du coup s'installe d'abord l'étonnement
plus d'inquiétude les semaines passent
de grandes zones de calme plat h/f de
décourager les hommes
à la fin du deuxième mois c'est la
grogne collomb fait face il rétabli le
calme
curieusement vérité étrangers ni la
personnalité de colomb est complexe en
tant que marin il mérite une
extraordinaire admiration admiration
pour ce premier voyage et pour les
voyages suivants
c'était vraiment un marin formidable par
contre quand nos juges aux colons en
tant que chef ministre at her
organisateurs il avait de grands défis
qui devait plus tard lui causé bien des
ennuis
les rois catholiques avaient promis une
récompense de 20 milles marins v10 ou
premier qui écrivait le premier qui le
fuit
c'est un pauvre matelot appelé rodrigo
des tri yann et bien chose
incompréhensible
chez un véritable chef christophe colomb
infirmait c'était lui le premier à avoir
vu la tête
il fit refuser la récompense aux pauvres
12 octobre 1492
au matin les pauvres rodrigo des tri
yann a donc trier
[Musique]
unis collomb la baptise san salvador il
ne sait pas où il est mais il sait qu'il
est sauvé
[Musique]
laissons un lointain descendant du
comité d'accueil l'historien haïtien
albert mollesse nous dire ce qui s'est
passé ensuite
c'est ici pour la première fois
christophe colomb le 6 décembre 492
toujours dans son esprit
découvrant le territoire fabuleux des
indes et en somme sur cet endroit et à
l'air aujourd'hui si désolée et qu'il
était d'ailleurs c'est ici qu'a commencé
un des chapitres les plus importants de
cette aventure extraordinaire qui a
bouleversé en somme tout le patrimoine
humain toute l'histoire de l'humanité
cette découverte d'un nouveau monde ici
sur cette terre d'haïti dans 69 jours
christophe colomb vient de traverser
l'atlantique
il a découvert les bahamas cubain et
haïti en somme il a découvert l'amérique
sans doute il a dû planter une croix au
babc le mans les caravelles et en a
marre et sont descendus en chaloupe et
nous ne savons pas exactement et
s'appuie très bien sur cette plage
quelconque banal où cette cérémonie qui
a été rapporté par tandis que rien a eu
lieu planté lacroix baigner à l'endroit
l'accueil a été remarquable d'ailleurs
il l'a toujours dit il l'a répété les
indigènes de set ils sont accueillants
gracieux charmant et sans doute les
points où il avait touché avant avait
permis de répandre la nouvelle de
l'arrivée de ces êtres extraordinaires
qui voyageait dans un esquif qui pour
nous aujourd'hui mais ce qu'un petit
mais mettez-vous à la place des indiens
saluer un choc extraordinaire de voir
ces énormes oiseaux avec leur voile
colossal arrivant sur la mer les blés
grande croix marqué dessus et en sortir
des êtres bizarres amis étrangement avec
une barbe et vêtu et chose étonnante et
il est si les ont accueillis pourtant
pas comme la tradition de tous les
hommes l'étranger l'ennemi ils ont
accueillis comme des amis et cette
première terre des antilles si elle
était riche de gentillesse elle était
riche d'un beau paysage d'accueil elle
était pauvre
finalement de ce pourquoi en effet vu ni
elle était pauvre d'or et les très
pauvres de de birac heureuse richesse et
malgré tout il ya eu l'entêtement de
ceux qui voulaient rien à voir on a
réduit en esclavage des indiens et ses
êtres si paisible n'ont pas résisté à ce
traitement
c'est le début d'une longue histoire
parfois douloureuses toujours exaltant
une autre histoire que nous allons vous
conter
l'homme était parti à la découverte du
monde dans les siècles suivants il
continue insatiable émerveillé les
grands voiliers apparaît superbe sur la
mer puis viendront les monstres cuirassé
les paquebots tous ces beaux navires de
cette belle aventure
[Musique]